right now in almost two dozen states
across the country Republicans who
control state legislators are working on
legislation we just saw one in Texas a
couple days ago that would make it a
felony to protest an oil pipeline or a
chemical plant or an oil refiner
refinery they want to make protesting
any of these so-called infrastructure
projects as they call them
a felony now the law that just passed
the house in Texas originally was going
to make it punishable by up to 20 years
in prison but they decided maybe that
was a little too harsh and they bumped
it down to now if this law passes you're
only going to get 10 years in prison for
protesting the placement of an oil
pipeline what's happening here is that
they're trying to argue that these
protesters come along and they interrupt
economic activity or they damage
critical pieces of fossil fuel
infrastructure now I understand we don't
like these pipelines and I do not
advocate damage to them of any kind
however a peaceful protest is allowed by
the Constitution just because you don't
like it doesn't mean you can pass a law
at the state level saying you can't do
this that's unconstitutional we have the
right to peaceably assemble here in the
United States you cannot take that away
just because you want to keep flooding
this country with fossil fuels and toxic
chemicals and yet that is exactly what
these states are working on and let me
go through some of the list here I
already mentioned Texas here we have
Oklahoma individuals who protest
pipelines can now be smacked with a one
hundred thousand dollar fine and 10
years in prison this is according to the
Sierra Club Louisiana says activists who
make unauthorized entry of a critical
infrastructure such as oil pipelines
face a punishment of up to five years in
prison and a $1,000 fine
North Dakota last march passed a law
under which interfering with pipeline
construction becomes a felony punishable
by up to five years in prison
in a $10,000 fine and groups conspiring
with such protests could be criminal
criminally liable for 10 times that
amount so $100,000 fine for anybody who
conspires with these protesters you know
perhaps a non-profit an environmental
organization that sets up these protests
see they're not just going after the
protesters themselves they're working on
ways written into these laws to defund
the organizations who helped organize
these events and these protests that's
phase two first you take away
everybody's First Amendment right saying
you cannot come and protest this
pipeline and the second is we're going
to bankrupt and punish the organizations
who are helping people organize these
protests that's a double whammy at this
point there's even more here and it's
it's absolutely discussing officials in
South Dakota are arguing that there are
limits to free speech when protest comes
into conflict with economic interests I
don't remember seeing that in the First
Amendment of the US Constitution III
don't think it said that our right to
peacefully assemble is limited as long
as it does not you know interfere with
economic activities other than that
you're good to go but hey you do
anything that might disrupt the flow of
Commerce then no suddenly you can't do
it that's not in the Constitution and
that's one of the reason why these laws
are likely to fail but again this is not
the first time we've seen a slew of laws
come into play at the same time we saw
shortly after Charlottesville
republican-controlled legislatures were
trying to make it illegal for people to
protest you have tried to limit where
they could or could not gather and this
wasn't in response to the horrible
people in Charlottesville this was in
response to the people who were
protesting the bad people all of this
boils down to the fact that they want to
take away our constitutional rights
that's what every one of these laws is
designed to do
otherwise they wouldn't feel the need to
do it but every one of these is likely
to get struck down in court even if it
goes up to one of the most conservative
justices in this country they understand
- regardless of their ideology that you
cannot infringe on that particular right
because if you do then what's going to
happen the next time somebody challenges
the second amendment right you know and
says we'll wait a minute
you've already dismantled the first
amendment why don't we start dismantling
the second one - that would actually
save lives here in the United States I
don't think that's ever going to happen
but it's something that these
conservatives need to have in their back
pockets so that they understand it at
all times you come after the amendments
that matter then you're gonna see people
coming after the only amendment that you
seem to care about but nonetheless we
should all be upset about this
regardless of your ideology they are
trying to strip us of our constitutional
rights and that is not something that is
ever okay in this country we're gonna
take a quick break but if you want even
more from me you can follow me on
Twitter at fair and balanced you can
find me on Instagram and Facebook at
fair and balanced I am fair and cousins
from Ring of Fire sitting in for David
Pakman and we'll be right back today's
sponsor is Skillshare and I'm excited to
tell you that everybody in our audience
is getting two entire months of free
access to Skillshare when you click the
link underneath this video skill shares
the site that offers over 25,000 online
courses on almost any topic you can
imagine cooking meditation photography
video editing Photoshop managing a small
business almost an endless list and
whether you're trying to get ahead in
your career maybe you want to learn new
skills that will make you better at your
job you might just be exploring a new
hobby and you're trying to find new ways
to be creative in your personal time
skill shares the perfect place to fully
immerse yourself in whatever you're
trying to learn I really enjoy
the class on more advanced video editing
techniques because it's something I've
been wanting to improve at but have been
very busy hosting the david packard show
for the last few years
once again the david pakman show is
giving you two whole months of access to
every single class offered by Skillshare
after those two months if you want to
keep your subscription Skillshare super
affordable at less than ten bucks a
month get better at whatever it is that
you're passionate about or discover
something brand new that you didn't even
know that you would love and join skill
shares other seven million users by
clicking the link underneath this video
[Music]